do you think Britain's in crisis no I
don't think it's about time that that
all the the different parties should be
united as a country we should be
Knightly United because I think would
just make the laughingstock to the rest
of the world so as a [ __ ] we should
come together sort that one but we need
the politicians to come together and
said of faintin we should be together
wish each other you have confidence in
Tereza mater deliver breakfast not
anymore I don't not anymore
I think Liam Fox and what do you think
should happen now then I think she
should step down gracefully gracefully
but I do think she's getting a raw deal
off the country after David Cameron
because he had nothing in place when he
took this crisis no I don't feel what in
crisis at all just no no I mean
obviously the last night's Parliament
was a record walk first time since
MacDonald we'd seen a result about it's
not the magnitude and be assured that
Parliament was able to speak over one
voice and say the deal simply wasn't
good enough and what's on the tables not
good enough for me I'll have to go back
get something else if she can't get
something else then let's go to a deal
absolutely confidence that we will be
strong enough to stand on its own two
feet so absolute confidence entities in
me I realized she what you'd remain she
stood on a platform at the last general
election that we she would deliver and
brexit she perhaps doesn't went in with
a strongest hand because she didn't have
a strong Parliament behind don't she's
beholden to some rebels but yep she's
doing the best deal and I certainly love
doing opposition benches that could just
be the job as to these amazed do I do
yes very much sir yeah it's as if you
know they're all arguing among
themselves and and can't come to a
conclusion on it and you know whether
it's going to go to a second referendum
or who knows not really no no well I
can't see any alternative for también if
you know would there be a change your
ladyship now it would throw things into
chaos and and you know so we'll just
have to wait and see I think and well I
would like to see it go through but
that's it very much of it if it will in
its in its present form at I think it
laughter with some radical changes and
how that's going to happen I don't
understand the notes of this that's why
they should never
in the first place what did the ordinary
people know about see look it's a mess
think it's an absolute mess I don't know
how we're gonna get out of it I think
she's in the best she can
I think the 50/50 split in the country
what else could she do half the country
is going to be unhappy personally I
think we should have another referendum
yes slightly I work in the construction
industry so there's just an uncertainty
as to what's going to happen in the
future with brexit I employ a lot of
labour on site and obviously with the
migration laws
it could affect me at some point in the
future I'd be surprised if she's in
power in seven days to be honest so what
do you want to see happen now I'd like
to see a second referendum because I
don't think it was adequately explained
on the first read for a referendum what
the yes and what the know was here the
government is definitely in crisis I
don't know about written I'm an optimist
I kind of think it'll be all right
but definitely the government's in
crisis yes I do actually and so I think
her deals will be the best we're gonna
get and I guess I'm kind of a little bit
disappointed that MPs and support it
I've really remain and but I think as if
we're gonna do brac sir
Theresa Mays deal Brax a deal was okay
so what should happen now I don't know
no idea right